>>> WE'RE LEARNING NEW
INFORMATION TONIGHT ABOUT
MYSTERIOUS INCIDENTS JUST STEPS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
SICKENED TWO NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIALS.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS WORKING THE
STORY FOR US.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GETTING THAT
NEW INFORMATION FROM YOUR
SOURCES.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT, WOLF,
WE ARE AND WE'RE TOLD THAT ONE
OF THOSE TWO OFFICIALS NEEDED TO
SEEK IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
TREATMENT.
ADDING TO THE CONCERN TONIGHT,
THESE TWO OFFICIALS WERE STRUCK
WITH THOSE ILLNESSES RIGHT HERE
IN ONE OF THE MOST HEAVILY
SECURED AREAS OF THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
AT THE PRESIDENT'S DOORSTEP, TWO
MYSTERIOUS INCIDENTS THAT HAVE
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS
SCRAMBLING.
MULTIPLE SOURCES TELL CNN
TONIGHT TWO WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS WERE STRUCK BY A
MYSTERIOUS ILLNESS, ONE HIT
WHILE THEY WERE NEAR AN ENTRANCE
TO THE WHITE HOUSE GROUNDS, THE
OTHER WHILE THEY WERE PASSING
THROUGH A GATE NEAR THE ELLIPSE
ON THE SOUTH SIDE OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
BOTH WERE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL OFFICIALS AND BOTH
INCIDENTS OCCURRED IN NOVEMBER,
SOURCES SAY.
THE CASES WERE CONSISTENT WITH A
SERIES OF STRANGE, DEBILITATING
ATTACKS AGAINST MORE THAN 100
U.S. DIPLOMATS AND INTELLIGENCE
PERSONNEL.
ONE THEORY SAYS THEY CAME FROM
DIRECTED MICROWAVE SIGNALS.
>> THERE'S ALSO A PSYCHOLOGICAL
IMPACT IN TERMS OF HOW THIS
ATTACK WAS LAUNCH AND WHY THIS
SPECIFIC LOCATION.
>> Reporter: IT'S CALLED HAVANA
SYNDROME BECAUSE THE UNEXPLAINED
SYMPTOMS STARTED WITH U.S.
DIPLOMATIC OFFICIALS IN CUBA
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO.
BUT SIMILAR ATTACKS ALSO
OCCURRED AGAINST DIPLOMATS AND
INTELLIGENCE OFFICERS IN RUSSIA,
CHINA AND ELSEWHERE.
SYMPTOMS INCLUDE EAR POPPING,
VERTIGO, POUNDING HEADACHES AND
NAUSEA.
A FORMER SENIOR CIA OFFICER SAYS
HE WAS HIT WHILE IN A MOSCOW
HOTEL IN 2017.
>> I WOKE UP IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT WITH AN INCREDIBLE
CASE OF VERTIGO.
THE ROOM WAS SPINNING.
I WANTED TO THROW UP AND GO TO
THE BATHROOM.
I HAD NEVER EXPERIENCED ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURY AFTER THAT ATTACK AND HAD
TO RETIRE FROM THE CIA.
>> I'D RATHER WOULD HAVE BEEN
SHOT.
>> Reporter: WHO ARE WHAT THE IS
THE PERPETRATOR?
IT COULD BE RUSSIA OR CHINA, BUT
THAT IS LARGELY CIRCUMSTANTIAL.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN DEVELOPING
MICROWAVE WEAPONS FOR YEARS.
>> THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BEST AT
THIS ARE THE RUSSIANS.
THEY'RE QUITE AMAZING, THEIR
ENGINEERS.
I WOULD SUSPECT IT'S THE
RUSSIANS AND IT'S A FLATOUT
INTELLIGENCE OPERATION RATHER
THAN TO HARM ANYBODY.
>> Reporter: RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
HAVE VEHEMENTLY DENIED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE ATTACKS,
AS HAVE CHINESE AND CUBAN
OFFICIALS.
EXPERTS SAY THEY DON'T BELIEVE
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS IN DANGER
WHILE HE'S INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT WHEN HE VENTURES
OUT?
>> IF IN THE LOW PROBABILITY
THAT THREAT WOULD PRESENT ITSELF
TO THE PRESIDENT, THE TIME TO
EXPOSURE WOULD BE MINIMAL WITH
QUICK REACTION BY THE SECRET
SERVICE.
>> Reporter: HOW CAN OTHER
AMERICANS DEFEND THEMSELVES FROM
THESE INCIDENTS?
CURRENT AND FORMER U.S.
OFFICIALS TELL CNN MULTIPLE
AGENCIES ARE DEVELOPING A KIND
OF SENSOR.
THAT CAN ONLY DETECT THE
ACTIVITY AND NOT REALLY PROTECT
ANYONE FROM IT.
CNN IS TOLD TONIGHT THESE
INCIDENTS ARE A